cal he is 7-3 with a 282 all the numbers
123 hits 143 innings he's been
outstanding his last start against these
royals went six and two thirds seven
hits just one run the two two
swag and a miss he struck him out to
start the game
nice and that'll be into center field
for his ninth hit of the trip well i
love how he adjusted to the breaking
ball kept his hands back
el salvador perez
hit hard and that is fair up the left
field line
nikki lopez to third vance wilson will
send him home
and the throw to relay man rosario was
short and cleveland had half their team
lined up
as relay men from the left field corner
the royals lead one nothing was kind of
funny looking but you know what not this
hit there it is middle salvi jumped all
over that ball was by the umpire and
everyone else before you could even see
it it was blistered man look at that
shot karim karen down there enough for
salvador press you can hear rusty coons
screaming from the dugouts come on come
on score so now salvi has a three rbi
advantage over jose abreu since the
indians have last seen jackson kowar he
has struggled but he pitched really well
against them at kauffman stadium back on
september the first
right field long run for dozier he won't
get it
on his way to second
and in safely with a leadoff double is
miles straw that is his 27th double of
the year and the indians try to come
right back here in the bottom of the
first and equal that royals run ahmed
rosario
he's had a good year against the royals
and he's trying to plug the gap here and
he will
that'll one hop defense go up into the
seats but the indians will tie the game
at one
rbi number 52 for rosario on his 24th
double of the year
there you go left field tagging up
rosario ben attendee comes up throwing
nowhere close
indians take the lead
give fred mill his 82nd run batted in on
the year two on indians here in the
first
yes change up and he picks up his first
strikeout of the game better than the 31
pitches he threw lasting
last time his first in
nice job
[Music]
high drive that's hit deep left center
field it is off the top of the wall
flying into second base with a one out
double is bradley zimmer that's his
eighth of the season
comes andreas jimenez
there it is left center field bingo
and that'll go to the wall and give the
indians another run as zimmer scores to
make it three to one what's wrong with
that approach right there
change up is pulled on the ground to
monday and he'll have to throw over him
in his head and the inning is over
cleveland gets two more doubles and
another run for a 3-1 lead
2-2 to the left-handed batter and he
shoots a fastball down the field line
that's a fair ball just inside the third
base bag it bangs off the tarp roller
down the left side just sort of dies
right there the left fielder mercato
coming in to make the play but kyle
isbell with his fifth big league double
to lead off this third inning
that is off of rosario
and into left field salvi's driven in
two
and it's 3-2 in the third inning
up hit in the air to right field
and zimmer won't get there it's off the
wall and now it bounces away from him
here comes salvia around third
and the relay will be offline and it
will get away
and allow ben and tendy to go to third
and he strikes him out to end the inning
but kansas city gets two runs on three
hits and we're tied at three middle of
the third ahead rosario leads off the
home half of the third
as
deep center field that's got a chance
and it's gone a home run for rosario how
about that he's two for two
and that's home run number eleven and
the indians go back in front four to
three
so we'll see what they do the third time
diving at 10 by whitmerfield couldn't
get it and miles straw just continues to
tear it up in the final month of the
season
and there you go number three he is
three for three and straw stops at
second we didn't get a a look at it you
were talking but when he you watch that
front foot he just got on it he just
raised his toe and came back down he
didn't have a stride but watch there it
is and come right back down and smokes
it just lifting the heel he yeah he's
quick through the hitting area look at
it it's all hands
and
one hopper but nobody's home he beat it
rosario beat lopez to the bag how about
that he did he out hustled him and
that's where the shift
hurt him bases loaded one out
and a broken back slow roller going
again
and they will get a run in and make it
5-3 bradley picks up rbi number 40.
[Music]
hunter dozier
is there so it could have been a lot
worse with the bases loaded and nobody
out cleveland gets one and they lead by
two two on two out then ahmed rosario to
the plate he is a perfect three for
three on the afternoon
and he's got the
[Applause]
cleveland
kyle zimmer will face his brother
bradley zimmer to lead off the bottom of
the eighth inning
he oh him
he got him
yes he did deep into the lower deck for
a solo home run
eighth of the year for zimmer and it's
7-3 cleveland oh baby
head down running hard he's gonna go for
two and he's gonna get it easily he's
gonna turn and burn what happened to
dozier he finally comes up with the ball
and hedges into third base
[Applause]
and ximena's lifts one
plenty deep enough
tagging hedges can jog home
and it's 8-3 cleveland the emmanuel
klossey on the pitch
the ninth
round ball to second
jimenez
throws it out book it
the final home game for the indians
is won by cleveland 8-3